wenig dumm oder ein wunderschöner morgen
erwartet uns hier in unserem ein
kraftfeld meine lieben frau was warum
ist ein fenster kaputt zunächst einmal
reparieren wir hier vorne die
glasscheibe keine ahnung was da passiert
ist
wir gehen jetzt am rother du kommst hier
raus noch ein schritt ja da lang los
jetzt meine fresse dann bleib seite wir
schauen uns erst mal ein bisschen um
alles seine richtigkeit noch besitzt
hier vorne das lagerfeuer steht noch
hier haben wir halt das creeper loch das
müssen wir noch ausbessern wir wir
entdeckten heute unsere insel bevor das
allerdings passiert habe mir viele
geschrieben ich soll dir so ein bisschen
den sand rum graben und das angeblich
hier irgendwo ne kiste sein
warum sind dann keine diamanten drin es
ist das herz des meeres was sich in der
heutigen folge auf jeden fall auto
machen wollte bevor wir die riesige boot
zu machen war dass ich diesen stecken
jetzt mal endlich fertig mache damit
nämlich
[Musik]
kann sein dass wir irgendwelche geister
heute auf der map haben mir wurde
nämlich auch in die kommentare
geschrieben dass der steg wohl deutlich
cooler aussehen soll wenn hier auch von
trampelpfad wäre genauso wie hier vorne
ich glaube ich muss hier einen dings
hinsetzen damit dass hierüber geht mit
der mit dem gras dann können wir nachher
mit der schaufel draufgehen und hier
genauso einen weg machen wir hier vorne
ihre das lagerfeuer setzt sich jetzt
auch einfach mal hier vorne dran dann
nehmen wir unsere schaufel machen das
auch aus sie haben für heute ein ganz
ganz anderen plan meine lieben freunde
und das sieht ja auch bereits im titel
eingeblendet wir entdecken heute unsere
welt in machen basic linie bootskorso
ein bisschen um unsere inseln rum zuvor
möchte ich allerdings wirklich noch
dieses kribbeln auch hier eben zu machen
war ja ich kann nichts real schock ich
kann nichts dafür dass man jobs und dumm
ist und in seine eigene piste feld alter
das war nicht ich der das in den
kommentaren gelesen dass man schafe
färben kann mit einem gelben fall ja
sieht jetzt nicht schön aus aber auf
jeden fall besser als vorher und wenn
das dann mit gras bewachsen ist dann
geht es vielleicht auch noch mal klar da
unten könnten toll dass man auch noch
schnell zusammen mehr sand hatte ich
jetzt gerade nicht dabei allerdings
müssen wir die insel reparatur folge
wirklich demnächst mal angehen das
kannst du die wirklich nicht anschauen
wie unsere inseln hier zerrupft wurde es
wird alles sehr sehr sehr sehr schön
ich gehe jetzt allerdings ganz kurz
schlafen weil schon wieder nacht wird
und ich weiß
deswegen gehe ich jetzt schlafen und
dann geht's los ein wunderschöner neuer
tag erwartet uns in unserer minecraft
welt dahin allerdings habe ich
versprochen meine lieben freunde wir
begeben uns nun auf große welt
entdeckungstour
darauf habe ich mich gerade schon bis
dafür habe ich mich gerade schon ein
bisschen vorbereitet und zwar mich halt
hier meine ganzen gegenstände gemacht
die ich halt braucht um sachen abzubauen
und um zu kämpfen ich habe meine anbauer
schild im wasser hängen oder was ich
habe mir alle mitgenommen weil ich
gedacht habe haye wenn ich im boot bin
kann ich ja eventuell
ja dann kann ich meinem boot angeln wir
waren ja letztes mal schon da hinten
beim piratenschiff deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht dass wir dort einfach wieder
hinfahren in die richtung weil dort ja
eventuell noch mehr piratenschiffe sein
könnten dementsprechend vielleicht ja
man braucht eigentlich auch so eine
richtig coole abenteuer musik jetzt wir
sind auf entdeckerreise meine lieben
freunde das ding haben ja schon letztes
mal ein bisschen auseinander gepflückt
wir haben hier vorne einen kleinen berg
ich weiß ja da in die höhlen drin sind
nun mal so ein bisschen drumherum fahren
ich hatte schiss dass überall jetzt
irgendwelche monster auftreten oder so
kann ich im boot essen wenn das geht
nicht wir haben hier vorne insel denn
die haben einen pelz be oben mit ganz
viel glück befinden sich dort pilz kühe
wie solchen die mit kriegen auf meine
insel schauen wir uns das hier erst mal
von der seite an das ist wirklich sehr
sehr geil weil bei so einer pilz crew
kannst du dir unendlich essen immer
holen da kann es mit einer schale
einfach richtig drauf machen dann hast
du pilzsuppe die sache ist wohl dafür
müssen wir welche finden da unten ist
glaube ich eine kleine höhle drin hier
ist keine pilz kurpark jetzt erstmal
hier vorne kann ich nämlich relativ gut
hochklettern zack so und jetzt sind wir
hier auf dem pilz bio meine lieben
freunde ich höre ich höre kühl
wir nehmen jetzt unser weizen das habe
ich eigentlich mitgenommen dass falls
ich verschollen gehe ich mir zumindest
die brote machen kann
und jetzt können wir die kühe
theoretisch fahren ich weiß nicht was
mir das jetzt hier bringt weil wir nicht
auf meiner insel sind allerdings haben
die jetzt eine ja wie kriege ich dir
jetzt rüber auf meine insel ein paar
sekunden später ja
herzlich willkommen bei minecraft mit
luca toni uns was wenn die uns nichts
tun dann ist es der schönste tag gerade
meinem leben schützen mit einer kur in
einem boot da hinten ist der sonntag ein
handy und ein delfin ist mit uns gerade
rom geschwommen
naja wie kriege ich dich denn jetzt hier
raus wir haben jetzt eine kuh hier ja
die will ich jetzt holen ich nehme
meinen weizen steige aus und versuche
jetzt eine von den kunden tätig das
sieht schon so schön aus minecraft mit
shader ist echt so das wunder schönste
spiel was es gibt ja eine super welt
entdeckungs folge bisher unsere insel
sieht schon schön aus ich bin ein
bisschen stolz auf mich selbst
das bin ich von opfer alter das ist
minecraft wir sind angekommen bei deinem
neuen zuhause meine liebe crusoe ich
baue das boot unter die ab so und du
kommst jetzt bitte mit genau hierhin ihr
beiden ich bei euch jetzt einfach schon
mal dann könnt ihr beiden nämlich schon
mal eine kleine baby zu bekommen und die
ist wir haben jetzt auf jeden fall
wieder kühe auf unserer insel meine
lieben freunde der ist sie schon gleich
selbstmordgefährdet mit dem abgrund hier
das passiert immer der nächste folgen
die insel reparatur und wir würde ich
sagen wir sind jetzt zwar schon die eine
richtung da hinten so ein bisschen
gereist wir werden jetzt noch mal die
komplett andere richtung reisen also
irgendwie noch da oder so und da er
nehme ich mein boot setzt es hier hin
setze mich dort rein und wir verlassen
unsere insel jetzt noch einmal in die
komplett andere richtung da vorne haben
wir zwar auch noch eine insel da war ich
allerdings schon kurz drauf vielleicht
erinnert ihr euch an die time jetzt wo
ich mein haus gebaut habe da brauche ich
eine menge holz und ich wollte nicht
meine eigenen
baumbestand abfällen von leibe nicht
vorübergegangen die insel war aber auch
relativ klein da würde ich sagen die mir
jetzt erstmal so in diese richtung
es gibt da vorne was interessant ist das
sieht so aus als wäre es auch einfach
eine ganz normale insel cool wer halt
wenn wir irgendwelche neuen bio
irgendwie entdecken würden oder so ich
finds halt echt so schön die
mittlerweile in minecraft dass sie auch
die unterwasserwelt richtig geil gemacht
haben mit den korallenriffen und so als
ich denke mal dass es das darstellen
soll die sache ist allerdings ich habe
sogar letzte nacht von diesem minecraft
projekt geträumt also ich weiß nicht ob
ich mich jetzt zu sehr einsteiger und zu
motivieren diese ganze sache ran hier
jedoch habe ich wirklich mega bock auf
dieses projekt und hatte gestern nach
den traum dass ich dieser kleine typ bin
und in meiner welt mich befinde auf
jeden fall von dem trauma halt so dass
auch creeper da waren und die kripo
waren halt einfach irgendwelche menschen
mit einem grünen umhang und nach um
schnell bombe da gab es glätte aber es
glätte waren diese biologie skelette an
denen irgendwie leer aber gezeigt dann
guck mal hier ist irgendwie der
oberschenkelknochen und hier ist dies
und hier ist dass die zombies sahen aus
wie zombies aus the walking dead also
nicht irgendwie so pixelig in minecraft
vor dem man halt 0,0 angst hat sondern
halt wirklich richtig ekelhaft
dann war es auch noch so dass ich halt
diese eisen rüstung an hat
[Musik]
wenig dumm
oder 11 was war das
[Musik]
hört ihr das
ich wollte ganz entspannt von meinem
traum erzählen
auf einmal ist hier ein dorf mitten im
wasser und irgend ein seeungeheuer will
mich tot sehen
ich weiß nicht ob ich den angeln kann
ich bin so ein bisschen perplex gerade
was hier abgeht ich entdecke plötzlich
mitten auf dem wasser ein dorf ich weiß
jetzt dass irgendein fehler ist von dem
spiel
[Musik]
eine wasserflasche habe ich gerne das
ist super ich wollte gerade noch
erzählen dass sich halt diese eisen
rüstung an hatte von dem typen und die
ich verstehe halt nicht wie er mit
seiner leisen hause laufen kann weil ich
war da drin und die zeit reisen war es
halt hart und ich musste die ganze zeit
so laufen so richtig langsam und konnte
dementsprechend von den zombies
weglaufen ist es hört sich wirklich dumm
an wenn man sagt dass man von minecraft
geträumt hat und das ein albtraum wahr
aber es war wirklich ein albtraum dann
musste ich halt mein feld neu bepflanzen
und ich bin halt die ganze zeit in
meinen schon bepflanzen felder
reingelaufen aber alles platt getrampelt
das war richtig ekelhaft und damit ich
halt raus gegangen und hier ist die
kiste chillig alter ich bin dann auf
jeden fall aus meinem feld raus gegangen
und da war es dann so dass er es ist
corona und ihr seid mehr als 31 ich bin
dann auf jeden fall von meinem feld
runter gegangen und ich habe diesen
kleinen knopf auf den boden gesetzt also
es war wirklich ein zu eins meiner
minecraft welt in der ich mich dort
befand und damit nicht einfach mit
meinen füßen auf den knopf aufgetreten
und ich mich gefragt wieso in minecraft
wenn ich meinen knapp drüber laufen mit
meinen füßen
wieso drückt man eben nicht bei den real
life in meinem traum in real life das
holz zu dumm an aber da ist das fertig
idiot werden auf jeden fall auf diesen
knopf draufgekommen habe alles
überschwemmt das komplette feld und habe
ich dann halt einfach als ich aufgewacht
bin gefragt habt ihr auch schon mal von
mir geträumt das verletzt mich irgendwie
dumm dekadent arrogant selbst verliebt
klingler erwartet aber wenn ich halt von
dem träume was ich am tag erlebt haben
ich habe gestern wirklich acht neun
stunden das minecraft video geschnitten
dann könnte es ja sein wenn ihr euch mal
videos von mir angucke dass ihr auch
schon mal von mir geträumt haben und der
gedanke der hat mich nicht mehr
losgelassen die bücherregale nehme ich
auch einfach mal mit das ist ein bücher
ständer den kann ich auch einfach mal
mitnehmen was haben wir hier oben noch
nie es gar nix ist nur ein kleiner
balkon ich leide jetzt einfach mal ganz
kurz das bettchen hier von irgendeiner
person aus ich weiß ja hier vorne eins
ist hier ist dass ich so was witzig will
mir eigentlich würde ich gerne im baum
ihr abfällen damit ich ein bisschen mehr
holz habe aber der sieht eigentlich echt
schön aus hier darauf generell ist das
haus das komplette dorf eigentlich sehr
schön also ich meine wahl muss natürlich
mitnehmen
ein bisschen essen und so weiter und so
fort kann nie schaden aber eigentlich
will ich das jetzt nicht so riesig
abfällen ich möchte allerdings in der
heutigen folge auf jeden fall noch
gucken ob hier nicht irgendwer noch eine
kiste stehen hat so dass ich mir da
eventuell ein bisschen was heraus necken
kann oder so vielleicht haben ja
diamanten oder emerald oder so stimmt
kann er mit ihnen auch handeln
ich habe meine e mails mit genug ich
habe mal
heute ich fahre jetzt zurück zu meiner
insel und verlasse das dorf ihr seht da
hinten zwar meine katze rom schwimmen
die sache ist allerdings dass sich
katzen ja teleportieren
ich hoffe dass das in dieser version
auch noch so ist aber damals als ich
meine kraft gespielt habe vor ein paar
jahren war es halt so dass sich katzen
zumindest wenn er längere zeit gegen die
im boot saß sich dann dahinter
deportiert haben wo man wieder
ausgestiegen ist von daher ist jetzt
wirklich daumendrücken angesagt meine
lieben freunde hier ist unsere spawnen
insel ja gewesen hier vorne wohnen wir
ja ich hoffe wirklich sehr sehr toll
dass nicht gleich aussteiger aus dem
bettchen und die katze quasi sich direkt
zu mir teleportiert das wäre schon
extrem geil ich bin jetzt zwar gerade
locker ein zwei minuten mit dem boot
gefahren also das dorf ist auf jeden
fall weit weg
allerdings vielleicht gibt's ja noch
näheres irgendwo nebenan was ich pack am
bootssteg mit meinem boot da habe ich
ihnen ja gebaut
allerdings finde ich ganz nett und man
kann diese zeit im boot dann eventuell
sogar dafür nutzen dass ich dann immer
irgendwelche fragen beantworte oder so
also wenn ihr möchtet stellt mir gern
fragen für die nächste bootstouren und
die kommentare die katze kommt natürlich
nicht mit der gehabt ich irgendwas
falsch gemacht mit der katze oder ich
irgendwie hätte ich die mit ins boot
nehmen können oder so tritt einmal unten
in die kommentare wenn euch die heutige
folge gefallen hat der lask einen daumen
hoch unter dem video abonniert man kann
einfach keine lucio seit ich habe
letztens gesehen dass mehr als die
hälfte meine videos cook und kein
abonnent sind also konstantes screaming
trees banks wir sehen uns mittwoch
wieder in einer neuen episode minecraft
mit luca wo wir die insel reparatur
machen werden
[Musik]